on a d'ailleurs appris ce matin que le
gaz européen s'enflammer de 60%
aujourd'hui à plus de 300 euros le
mégawattheure cela inquiète tout le
monde et en premier lieu les italiens
natalia m de ça bonjour nathalie en
direct de rome les italiens
particulièrement inquiet puisque
fortement dépendants du gaz russe
oui effectivement l'italie importe 90%
du gaz consommé dans le pays et de ses
approvisionnements près de 40% assez du
gaz qui vient de la russie voilà
pourquoi cette guerre a déjà d un impact
très réel très concrets pour les ménages
des italiens qui ont vu leur facture
d'électricité flambé ces dernières
semaines 60 % de l'électricité produite
en italie est produite en utilisant du
gaz une situation qui inquiète
particulièrement le gouvernement italien
qui a donc proposé plusieurs mesures
pour essayer de briser cette dépendance
du gaz russe d'abord augmenter
l'importation de gaz qui provient
d'autres pays comme le gaz liquéfié qui
arrivent notamment des états unis où le
gaz qui arrive de l'algérie à travers le
gazoduc transmed qui qui relie l'algérie
à la sicile autre hypothèse c'est celle
de réactiver des centrales à charbon qui
devait être définitivement et bien
désactiver d'ici 2025 et bien ils seront
vraisemblablement réactiver dans les
prochains jours finalement le recours
aux énergies renouvelables mais ceci
reste évidemment une
une solution aux moyens ou enrôlant long
terme natalia
on on va faire aujourd'hui un tour
d'europe se rendent chez nos voisins
européens pour tenter de percevoir
comment la population européenne perçoit
perçoit cette cette crise ce conflit
comment la guerre est-elle vécue chez
vous en italie
elle est vécue avec une grande
inquiétude les italiens vraiment envie
d'aider les ukrainiens les familles
d'ukrainiens qui commencent déjà à
arriver on voit ces jours ci un
véritable élan de solidarité avec des
initiatives qui se multiplient pour le
don de biens de première nécessité pour
l'aide concrète aux réfugiés qui
commençaient à arriver pour les familles
qui déjà des familles d'italiens qui se
met à disposition pour accueillir les
enfants ukrainiens qui arrive seul ou
accompagné
il faut savoir que l'italie abrite
alors la liaison interrompue avec
liaison interrompue avec natalia mendoza